m mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
après l'adaptation des modes d'action de
l'État Arem mardi nous lançons ce matin
nos travaux sur la coopération régionale
des outresmèes pour laquelle nous avons
nommé un rapporteur coordonateur euh
cher Christian camban ancien président
de la commission des Affaires étrangère
et trois binômes de rapporteurs soit un
binôme par bassin donc pour le bassin
Pacifique madame Eveline Corbière Namo
sénateur de la Réunion et rachide et
rachide téal sénateur du valdoise pour
le bassin Atlantique taro
frit
sénateur de la Polynésie et Jacqueline
eustach brigot et pour le bassin indien
George passion sénateur de la Guyane et
Stéphane de pour cette première audition
nous recevons Son Excellence Monsieur
Jean-Paul Guillaumet ambassadeur délégué
pour l'action extérieure des
collectivité territoriales auprès du
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Monsieur l'Ambassadeur nous
vous remercions pour votre présence qui
va nous permettre d'annoncer notre
panorama de l'action extérieure des
collectivités
d'outremer concernant le déroulé de
cette réunion je vais laisser la parole
à notre rapporteur coordonate Christian
com et après au collègues pour les
questions sur le
sujet merci madame la présidente madame
la Présidente Monsieur l'Ambassadeur mes
chers collègues donc en qualité de de
rapporteur
coordonnateur de ce groupe de travail je
souhaiterais rapidement peut-être
évoquer les raisons du choix de ce thème
d'étude et
esquisser quelques axes de réflexion de
perspective
car le danger dans ce genre de sujet
c'est de se disperser donc il faut bien
évidemment tenter de tracer un un
parcours pour participer à la réflexion
sur ce difficile sujet qui est celui de
l'action extérieure des collectivités
territoriales alors pourquoi a-t-on
retenu autour de vous présidente
cette ce ce choix ce ce sujet moi-même
n'étant pas spécialisteom puisque je ne
réside pas évidemment dans un de ces
territoires mais l'expérience que j'ai
pu acquérir tant au titre de la
commission des affaires étrangères que
de celle de la défense la même
commission ça me donne le sentiment
que les territoires ultramarins français
sont encore sensiblement trop faiblement
inséré dans leur environnement régional
alors bien évidemment c'est lié
certainement à la faute à des relations
historiques avec la métropole et
j'utilise à dessin ce terme car c'est
bien une relation de de dépendance par
rapport à un centre qui est souvent
critiqué cette situation est considérée
notamment comme un frein au
développement économique et aussi une
des causes de la chireté de la ville
elle peut aussi étouffer le rayonnement
culturel universitaire ou scientifique
des territoires ultramarins dans leur
bassin de vie
respectif pourtant la coopération
régionale présente un intérêt réciproque
du point de vue des territoires elle
doit favoriser leur insertion régionale
et leur développement endogène dans le
respect de leur identité vu du point de
vue de la France de la métropole les
outremères intégrées participent à
l'accroissement de notre influence et on
va de même pour l'Union européenne à
travers les rupes en particulier mais
également les
PTOM la coopération doit être aussi un
facteur de stabilisation et de
sécurité de plus en plus et ça c'est un
sujet que nous avions bien noté à la
commission des affaires étrangères les
les outres mèes sont exposés à des
risques environnementaux mais aussi des
risques
géostratégiques dans le jeu des
relations internationales ces
territoires peuvent être la cible de
tentativ de déstabilisation et de jeux
d'influence les enjeux de police et de
sécurité sont aussi croissant face à des
réseaux criminels particulièrement
puissants alors ce tableau évidemment
nous invite à faire un choix d' à faire
un certain nombre de choix et notamment
le le choix d'un état des lieux de la
coopér régionale et nous interroger sur
les raisons des limites actuelles de
cette stratégies tout en proposant
quelques pistes de
réponses à travers à côté pardon des
enjeux transversaux nous avons décidé
d'opter pour une approche par bassin
tout le défi étant précisément de
développer la coopération en l'appuyant
sur les atouts et les caractéristiques
de chaque territoire dont évidemment
tout le monde sait ici qu'il peut être
aussi très différent en portant des
problématiques
communes à mon sens enfin deux ou trois
objectifs de la coopération régionale
doivent être explorés plus avant
l'objectif de sécurité et de
stabilisation des territoires nous nous
vivons dans une période de grande
instabilité mondialein où les grandes le
jeu des grandes puissances peut
effectivement les conduire à lancer un
certain nombre de provocations y compris
comme des sur des pays comme les nôtres
l'objectif bien sûr du développement
économique qui est au cœur de la
préoccupation des de l'outrem enfin
celui de la transition écologique et
énergétique qui est étroitement lié au
précédents on se souvient au aux anti et
singulièrement à Saint-Martin euh des
conséquences dramatiques qu'un ouragan a
entraîné sur cette partie de l'île
déstabilisant une bonne partie de son
économie alors votre audition Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur va permettre d'éclairer
une partie de ces thèmes les
collectivités ultramarines sont
demandeuses de plus d'actions de
coopération régionale certaines
déploient déjà des action action
extérieure nombreuses nous souhaitons
avoir votre regard sur l'intensité de
ces actions leur orientation le soutien
que l'État leur apporte et vos services
en l'occurrence comment pouvez-vous agir
pour les les aider et les soutenir
au-delà de tous ces sujets nous
souhaiterions savoir si ces actions
permettent de dessiner une véritable
stratégie de coopération régionale en
appui ou en complément de notre
diplomatie franç 16 voilà Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur quelques interrogations
qui ne sont pas exhaustives bien sûr et
que les rapporteurs par bassin pourront
enrichir à la suite de votre exposé
liminaire si lorsque la présidente vous
donnera la
parole merci chers collègues je salue
l'arrivée de nos rapporteurs et je vais
vous laisser la parole pour un propos
liminire 10 15 minutes comme vous
le
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs je voudrais
euh tout d'abord vous remercier de me
donner l'occasion de venir à votre
rencontre
euh mais pour éviter euh tout malentendu
pour éviter de se disperser comme le
notait euh monsieur le le rapporteur je
voudrais commencer par quelques
précisions sur ce que fait la
délégation pour l'action extérieure des
collectivités territoriales du ministère
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
alors tout d'abord mais c'est presque
anecdotique sachez que le poste que
j'occupe depuis Guire plus de 2 ans va
être prochainement supprimé et cette
activité de
soutien aux collectivités territoriale
qu'elle soit métropolitaine ou
ultramarine
sera confié à un bureau au sein d'une
plus grande délégation
euh étant à la fois l'interface avec les
collectivité territoriale mais également
la société civile les
organisations de solidarité
internationale donc un spectre nettement
plus large que la daect la daect je ne
vais à vous faire toute son histoire a
commencé comme
délégation auprès du Premier ministre a
été ensuite rattaché au secrétaire
général du quéorset puis auprès du
directeur général de la
mondialisation et donc maintenant sera
donc dans une plus grande délégation la
deuxème précision que je voulais
apporter et au risque de décevoir une
partie de d'entre vous et je suis
vraiment confus de vous le dire dès
maintenant la daect n'a jamais été
compétente pour le bassin Pacifique nous
ne sommes compétents que pour deux
océans sur trois si je puis dire ou deux
bassins sur 3 alors j'ai par
curiosité cherché à comprendre pourquoi
elle avait été construite ainsi c'est
parce que la CTA qui a quand même plus
de 20 ans d'existence sous ces
différentes formes
euh prenait déjà en compte le fait que
les territoires français dans le
Pacifique jouissaiit déjà d'un statut
particulier dans la conduite de leurs
relations avec des états étranger alors
que à l'époque de la création de la
daect les collectivités
ultramarines du euh bassin Atlantique ou
du bassin indien était j'irais doté des
mêmes compétences que les collectivités
métropolitaines ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui bien sûr nous y reviendrons
la remarque que je voudrais également
formuler au début de cet exposé c'est
que l'action extérieure des
collectivités
territoriales a des dimensions très
varié même si peut-être la plus ancienne
et la mieux connue est la solidarité
internationale qui a souvent une
dimension
diasporique qui entretient souvent des
des liens historiques entre certains
territoires et euh des collectivités à
l'étranger euh il y a aussi beaucoup
d'autres aspects les conseils régionaux
par exemple sont aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus préoccupés d'attractivité euh
d'accompagnement des des entreprises qui
ne sont uniquement concern né par la
solidarité internationale mais un point
très important c'est que le législateur
n'a
pas
délimiter les
compétences internationales les
compétences à l'étranger des
collectivités territorial et rien
n'empêche par exemple un conseil
départemental de mener sur un territoire
étranger un projet de coopération
décentralisée dans le domaine économique
qui n'est plus aujourd'hui peut-être de
la compétence nationale du conseil
départemental de la même manière un
conseil régional peut se lancer dans un
projet qui a un lien avec des sujets
comme la petite enfance ou autrre qui
sont de la compétence du conseil
départemental et à la daect et plus
généralement tous
ceux au sein du ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères et bien sûr avec
nos collègues de l'Agence française de
développement donc tous ceux qui
viennent en soutien
de cette action extérieure des
collectivités territoriales nous devons
bien sûr respecter les choix qui sont
faits par les élus de se lancer dans tel
ou tel projet même si encore une fois ce
n'est pas dans la compétence
première à titre je dirais national de
la collectivité territoriale en
question j'ai bien compris que l'objet
de votre étude portait sur la
coopération régionale
outreem mais je voudrais je je m'en
voudrais de ne pas euh mentionner euh un
sujet qui
euh suscite toujours beaucoup plus
d'intérêt de la part des élus euh
ultramarins euh c'est la coopération
décentralisé avec l'Afrique de l'Ouest
euh autour de euh des questions
mémorielles euh beaucoup de projets en
particulier euh dans les Antilles sont
euh montés parfois fois avec beaucoup de
difficultés on reviendra sur cette
question plus tard avec des partenaires
d'Afrique de l'Ouest euh il n'y a donc
pas qu'une seule dimension à l'action
extérieure des collectivités
ultramarines qui consisterait à les
intégrer dans leur je dirais
environnement le plus
immédiat de la même manière puisque je
je prenais un exemple
euh du côté des des Antilles sachez que
certains partenaires je pense en
particulier au Québec et à ces
collectivités territoriales sont très
présentes dans les relations de nos
Antilles c'est une question
d'ailleurs qui peut parfois susciter de
l'inquiétude sachant que le Québec
affiche clairement comme priorité de
recruter des jeunes euh des euh euh
territoires français euh des Antilles
euh ben pour résoudre des question de
main d'œuvre bien formé et euh plutôt
qualifié donc il y a cet effet aussi
d'attraction du Québec sur les Antilles
donc qu'il ne faut pas négliger mais
encore une fois j'ai bien compris que le
sujet était essentiellement la
coopération régionale qui s'entend donc
pour nos Antilles avec le bassin
caribéen ou avec avec les autres
environnements immédiats alors la daect
dont j'ai la la responsabilité est un
service d'une douzaine
d'agents certains sont mis à disposition
par d'autres ministères le ministère de
l'Intérieur et des autres ma bien sûr
nous avons eu un moment
aussi des collègues mis à disposition
par le ministère en charge de la
transition écologique bon sous ces
différentes appellations ou ministère de
l'Agriculture actu éement il n'y a de
mise à disposition que de du ministère
de l'Intérieur et des autres maires le
budget dont dispose la daect est de 13
millions d'euros en
2023 ce qui je dirais correspond à son
rôle de de soutien à des initiatives qui
viennent des collectivités territoriales
et je l'ai déjà mentionné nous
travaillons en très bonne intelligence
avec l'Agence française de développement
qui prend souvent le relais du ministère
et de sa daect pour soutenir des projets
plus importants avec des investissements
je pense en particulier à un secteur
tout à fait privilégié de la coopération
décentralisée l'eau et
l'assaainissement alors les principales
activités de la daect sont tout d'abord
d'assurer le secrétariat général de la
Commission nationale de la coop
opération décentralisée cette commission
est
placée sous la présidence de la première
ministre elle se réunit dans différents
formats en particulier une session
pliniiaire deux fois par an alors
les premier ministres ont la faculté
bien sûr de déléguer le le le soin la
charge de présider cette session
plinière au ministre des Affaires
étrangères mais pour les trois dernières
sessions pliniiare c'est la secrétaire
d'État madame zakaropouou qui a présidé
au nom du gouvernement donc la daect est
avant tout donc ce secrétariat général
de cette commission cette commission
réunit des élus qui sont désignées par
de grandes associations les grandes
associations que nous avons coutume
d'appeler les
fétières région de France département de
France l'association des maires de
France et euh des euh associations qui
sont plus euh spécialisées je pense à
euh la fccre l'Association Française du
Conseil des communes et régions d'Europe
euh je pense à l'association cités unif
France je pense à France urbain et euh
également euh dans le domaine de la
Francophonie qui est une de nos
priorités euh laimf et
lairf l'une pour les maires et l'autre
pour les régions euh francophones donc
ces institutions participent à à aux
travaux de la CNCD avec des
représentants des différents ministères
j'insiste sur la non seulement la
présence mais la participation toujours
très active du ministère en charge des
outresomèes donc aujourd'hui c'est
direction générale des des autres maires
la l'intérêt de soutenir la la
coopération des décentralisé émanant de
collectivité ultramarine et toujours
réaffirmé occasion des sessions
plinières de la CNCD mais également dans
les réunion de ces groupes de travail
ensuite la daect a une vocation générale
de participer à la promotion de la
coopération décentralisée de
l'internationalisation des des
territoires elle le fait par des
séminaires elle le fait par des actions
de sensibilisation alors nous ne faisons
pas seul nous faisons bien sûr avec la
chance française de développement nous
le faisons avec également d'autres
ministères je pense au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale bien sûr pour tout
ce qui est éducation à la citoyenneté et
à la solidarité
internationale alors le soutien que nous
apportons je dirais concrètement aux
collectivités territoriales françaises
peut prendre plusieurs formes la forme
peut-être la plus ancienne et la plus
classique c'est celle d'app appel à
projet nous avons chaque année des
appels à projet qui qui sont soit
généralistes soit thématiqu alors
l'avantage des appels à projets
thématiques c'est qu'il nous permettent
de refléter des priorités de la
diplomatie française et de la politique
française en général nous avons certains
appels à projet depuis quelques années
dans le domaine du sport dans le domaine
de la
jeunesse mais nous en avons plus
récemment lancé en matière d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes en
matière de
numérique responsable et inclusif en
matière de sécurité alimentaire ou de
soutien aux finances locales donc ça
permet à chaque fois de signaler aux
collectivités territoriales françaises
que bien évidemment nous examinerons
tous les projets à partir du moment où
bien sûr ils sont suffisam muris et qui
ne sont pas contraires aux engagements
internationaux de la France mais ça va
s'en dire mais nous avons aussi la
manière de signaler quelques priorités
nous avons aussi avec certains grands
partenaires je pense en particulier au
Liban au Sénégal au
Maroc des dispositifs conjoints alors
qui fonctionne chacun de manière un
petit peu spécifique mais qui permettent
d'associer C généralement la direction
générale des en charge des collectivités
locales d'un ministère de l'Intérieur
qui qui qui s'occupe de cela mais ça
permet de de signaler une priorité pour
ces pays-là et d'organiser ça de manière
tout à fait concertée réfléchie et avec
l'appui souvent donc des gouvernements
de ces grands partenaires enfin nous
avons euh très récemment lancé un appel
à manifestation d'intérêt donc il faut
que j'en un tout petit peu différemment
mais dans la perspective du sommet du
festival de la Francophonie puisque la
France vous le savez accueillera le
Sommet de la Francophonie à villercotray
et à Paris en fin 2024 nous souhaitons
valoriser ce que font les collectivités
territoriales dans leur aspect je dirais
international sur le thème de la
Francophonie nous avons aussi d'autres
programmes en cours d'élaboration je
pense en particulier en matière de
soutien aux 10 villes françaises qui
font partie du réseau des villes
créative de l'UNESCO mais encore une
fois tout cela c'est complémentaire il y
a toujours l'appel à projet généraliste
qui permet
d'examiner toutes sortes d'initiatives
que peuvent prendre les collectivités
territoriales en matière d'action
extérieure alors l'action extérieure des
collectivités territoriales nous
l'examinons Ave avec des partenaires
comme lafd avec des représentants donc
des grandes associations dont j'ai déjà
parlé celles qui siège en CNCD
euh ce qui est important en fait pour
nous ce sont je dirais deux grands
principes le premier c'est qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un engagement politique de
part et d'autres
euh ce que nous soutenons cette
coopération décentralisée ce n'est pas
une coopération technique j' dirais
comme les autres qui est tout à fait
respectable il faut vraiment qu'il y ait
cet engagement qui se matérialiste par
la
signature d'un élu français et d'un élu
du pays partenaire parce que la
coopération décentralisée doit se
caractériser par des échanges entre élus
et pas seulement entre services
techniques pour la conduite d'un projet
spécifique après les projets bon peuent
c'est allé de 1 an à 3 ans il peuvent
être renouvelés on fait tout ce qu'il
faut pour je dirais les ajuster les
corriger parce que bien
évidemment les collectivités
territoriales
interviennent dans des pays qui sont
particulièrement troublés je pense au
Liban je pense au territoire palestinien
euh je dirais souvent les territoires
d'intervention ne sont pas simples et il
peut y avoir des sousbressau nous les
accompagnons
toute la durée du projet nous apportons
notre soutien sous forme de
cofinancement qui peut aller jusqu'à 80
% du montant total du projet mais encore
une fois nous ne faisons pas le projet à
la place de la collectivité c'est elle
qui doit avoir l'idée c'est elle qui
doit trouver le partenaire c'est elle
qui doit le mettre en œuvre alors elle
n'est pas seule il y a des opérateurs
qui sont parfois à l'échelle régionale
ou
parfois qui sont plutôt regroupés par
pays d'intervention mais voilà en
quelque sorte très rapidement comment
nous fonctionnons nous avons aussi comme
mission de
soutenir la place des collectivités
territoriales dans les grandes enceintes
internationales c'est un sujet qui prend
toujours plus d'ampleur il y a
des conférences de d'association de
collectivité territorial et force de
constater que la voix de la France est
peut-être de plus en plus faible ou
peut-être celle de ses opposants est de
plus en plus forte mais il n'est pas
rare maintenant que la France et
l'Europe soient mis en difficulté par
des prises de position de lors de ces
grandes réunions de collectivité
territoriale ce qui est important pour
nous c'est aussi de faire entendre la
voix des collectivités territoriales
dans les grands rendez-vous nous sommes
au main de la COP c'est un
exemple puisque nous savons que les
objectifs du développement
durable seront en
partie atteints grâce à l'action des
collectivités territoriales tout ne sera
pas décidé à l'échelon national ou à
l'échelon supranational européen une
bonne partie de la mise en œuvre des
objectifs de développement durable passe
parce que l'on appelle souvent leur
territorialisation donc leur décline
ison au niveau des collectivités
territoriales enfin je voudrais
mentionner que la DA euh peut s'appuyer
sur un réseau important de conseillers
diplomatiques près des préfets de région
conseillers diplomatique près des
préfets de région ce sont des collègues
du kéorset qui sont placés auprès du
préfet pour le
conseiller ben dans la conduite des
relations avec les par partenaires
étrangers alors ça peut être pour des
questions je dirais plus de
protocolairire ou parce que beaucoup
d'ambassadeurs en poste à Paris ont
compris que tout ne se passait pas dans
dans dans la capitale et qu'il fallait
souvent se
rendre dans les territoires ça peut être
aussi pour certaines questions un petit
peu compliquées lorsqu'une collectivité
territoriale adopte une motion ou prend
position sur une question internationale
et alors bien évidemment ce sont nos
collègues du ministère de l'Intérieur
qui ont la tâche d'assurer le contrôle
de l'égalité mais quand ça porte sur des
sujets internationaux nous travaillons
en bonne intelligence la DGCL et la DAC
grâce au CDPR alors je voudrais relever
que dans ce réseau des conseillers
diplomatiques près des préfets de région
quatre sont en outre ma réunion Mayot
Guyane et Guadeloupe encore une
fois nous n'avons pas de CDPR en tant
que tel dans le territoire du Pacifique
même s'il y a sous une autre forme des
diplomates qui servent pour conseiller
les services déconcentrés de
l'État voilà en quelques mots ce que je
pouvais vous dire pour quelque sorte
planter le décor circ insrire ce que
nous faisons nous pouvons faire à la la
daect en toute honnêteté je dois vous
dire que même si la priorité ultramarine
est réaffirmée à chaque réunion de la
session plainère de la Commission
nationale de la coopération
décentralisée
concrètement c'est peut-être avec ces
collectivité là que nous avons le plus
de difficultés à soutenir des projets de
coopération des centralisé et et nous
n'avons pas une action
spécifique qu'il faudrait peut-être
développer qui existe du côté de
l'Agence française de développement mais
voilà nous avons bien conscience de
l'enjeu mais
malheureusement je dois avouer que nous
n'en avons pas fait suffisamment
certainement parce qu'il y a une forte
appétence pour la coopération
décentralisée de la part des élus
ultramarins mais encore une fois peu de
résultats concrets merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente et monsieur le rapporteur
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je vais
laisser la parole à ma collègue
Jacqueline
stage merci merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
pour toutes les informations que vous
venez donner je voulais revenir si vous
le voulez bien sur les appels à projet
dont vous avez parlé qui sont donc
soutenus voilà par différents ministères
est-ce qu'on a une idée du montant qui
ont été affectés au au aux projets qui
ont été validés le nombre le nombre de
projets alors moi je m'occupe du bassin
atlantique mais c'est intéressant qu'on
ait le tout parce qu' a voilà sur le
nombre de de par exemple sur l'année
2022 on n'est pas obligé de retourner
très loin mais sur l'année 2022 combien
de projets ont été validé quel montant
et un petit peu dans quel domaine ces
projets
étai étai concernés voilà sur quel sujet
particulièrement on pouvait vérifier ce
qui se passait et est-ce que vous aviez
donné des priorités Moon voilà est-ce
qu'il y avait une orientation sur ces
projets ou est-ce que c'était
complètement ouvert j'ai envie de dire
merci beaucoup madame le sénateur pour
cette question alors tout d'abord euh
pour assurer je dirais la qualité de de
vos travaux je me permettrai
éventuellement de communiquer ensuite
les chiffres les plus précis parce que
vous m'interrogez sur 2022 bien
évidemment mes excellents collaborateurs
m'ont préparé quel quelque chose sur
2020 2022 et je n'ai pas une rapidité de
calcul suffisante pour faire
mainten c'est bien ça donne une voilà je
vois que ça
site tu l'as ici voilà par bassin mais
encore une fois la la DA C c'est un
budget de 13 millions en
augmentation l'année 2024 n'a pas encore
commencé et on peut toujours avoir des
surprises en cours d'année mais nous
devrions commencer 2024 avec un budget
de de 15 millions euh pour ce qui est
des collectivités ultramarines donc des
deux bassins Atlantique et et indien
nous avons de 2020 à
2023 un montant total de projets de
l'ordre de 4 millions d'euros j'ai un
chiffre de
378 mais il faudrait voir ensuite après
le cycle du projet puisque nos projets
vont souvent jusqu'à 36 mois nous les
examin en début d'année c'est un peu
fictif de croire que nous allons
consommer un/ers en première année
puisque le dépôt du projet ensuite son
examen la lettre de notification on est
déjà au mois de mai juin et dans les
collectivité ultramarinees comme dans
les métropolitaines le mois de juillet
n'est pas le mois d'août ne sont pas
exactement les mois les plus actifs donc
très souvent le projet ne commence
réellement qu'en septembre ou octobre
donc la la première année dépasse une
année de Fort décaissement et souvent
les projets se prolongent un petit peu
mais donc pour fixer les idées de
l'ordre de 4 millions et avec un soutien
de la DAEC de
1700000 environ alors je peux encore une
fois on vous communiquera des chiffres
beaucoup plus précis mais ce qui montre
une certaine modestie des projets mais
en revanche
les les les
thèmes le sport est souvent très
représenté euh je pense à différents
domaines alors le sport dans une
dimension inclusive éducative ce n'est
pas seulement le sport jeais pour la
performance physique hein
euh vous avez la coopération culturel
linguistique parce que nos élus dans les
collectivités ultramarines sont bien
conscients du fait que peut-être plus
encore que quand on est en en métropole
ben les voisins parlent pas
nécessairement votre langue euh et là il
y a plusieurs langues aussi qui se
parlent dans dans la Caraïbe par exemple
donc beaucoup de choses sont faites
parce que l'apprentissage linguistique
est indispensable à la formation de la
jeunesse donc voilà beaucoup de choses
des petites choses aussi dans le domaine
de des filières agricoles euh de la
petite agriculture de l'agriculture
vivrière l'agriculture urbaine aussi
c'est un domaine euh qui euh est
particulièrement important nous
souhaiterions nous-même encore une fois
he tout en laissant l'initiative aux
collectivités territorial en faire
peut-être davantage dans le domaine de
la préservation de la biodiversité euh
la France tout entière doit beaucoupe à
ces outremers pour la
biodiversité nous avons soutenu
des projets portés par la Fédération
nationale des parcs naturels régionaux
c'est une chose d'ailleurs que j'ai
oublié de dire dans ma présentation nous
intervenons directement auprès des
collectivités territoriales mais nous
soutenons aussi des projets portés par
des associations de collectivité
territorial je pense par exemple la
Fédération nationale des parcs naturels
régionaux je pense aussi à beaucoup
d'associations de collectivités
territoriale française il en a à peu
près autant que de collectivité non
j'exagère mais euh qui qui se regroupe
sur un thème que ce soit le patrimoine
naturel le patrimoine historique nous
les aidons à porter des projets à
l'international merci beaucoup madamee
question alors peut-être que vous avez
répondu et vous êtes je n'ai pas noté
est-ce qu'il y a une coordination
officielle entre commune département
région est-ce qu'il y a un pilote dans
l'avion j'envie dire NON NON ni dans les
outres mes ni il y a peut-être une
spécificité pour
non non non il y il y a pas de pilote
parce que le principe justement encore
une fois c'est que aucune collectivité
territoriale n'a l'obligation de faire
quoi que ce soit avec un partenaire
étranger j'exagère un tout petit peu
parce que je pense que certaines en
particulier dans zone frontalière mais
également du coup en autre mer ont
presque pas ressence besoin de
travailler avec leurs voisins mais très
franchement
euh
35500 communes en France les régions les
départements son voilà euh au fond euh
l'action extérieure des collectivités
territoriales c'est un jeu avec une
centaine de joueurs euh dont 10 gros
joueurs euh et malheureusement les
collectivités ultramarines ne sont pas
parmi ces 10 gros euh des plus gros
joueurs euh de l'action extérieure des
collectivités
territoriales merci euh alors j'ai
rachide qui voulait intervenir puis
après Vivette et après Jean
bonjour Alors moi je suis rapporteur sur
la partie sur l'autorité bien sûr
Christan comambon sur l'autorité sur le
le le bassin Pacifique moi j'ai
plusieurs questions d'abord la première
question c'est vous évoquez votre budget
et vous dites 13 millions et l'année
prochaine 15 15 millions pardon ma
question c'est en action est-ce que la
part action et fonctionnement ou alors
c'est seulement de l'action ça c'est ma
première question la la deuxème question
c'est sur vous évoquez le fait qu'il y a
des conseils diplomatiques auprès des
préfets de région c'est une bonne chose
euh peut-être si vous pouvez évoquer un
peu leur rôle pas tant sur comment on
reçoit un ambassadeur mais surtout sur
comment il a il a il peut aider à à
justement développer ses ses relations
diplomatiques ou en tout cases ses
relations extérieures et pourquoi pas
dans le le territoire du Pacifique
est-ce que
c'est c'est parce que c'est pas encore
développé ou c'est prévu au-delà de ce
que vous avez dit sur d'autres systèmes
et la question c'est pourquoi il en a
pas dans le dans le Pacifique et puis
après moi j'ai deux autres
questions euh dans vos dans vos missions
vous avez le rôle d'élaboration de
textes juridiques notamment sur les
coopérations transfrontalières est-ce
que vous pouvez donner des exemples sur
justement cell concernant l'outreem sur
les 3 qu C dernières années et puis une
dernière question c'est sur un exemple
concret qui peut être plus fonctionnel
j'envie de dire c'est sur la question
euh euh de la coopération euh
transfrontalière entre Saint-Martin et
la partie nérlandaise de lillele et
peut-être là-dessus nous en dire un peu
plus euh et puis dernier point alors là
c'est c'est c'est ma marotte euh moi qui
était rapporteur corapporteur du texte
de loi sur l'aide public au dévelppement
euh donc c de 2021 enfin la loi de
programmation en cours d'ailleurs j'ai
envie de dire euh je ne comprends
toujours pas qu'on puisse faire que
l'AFD intervienne sur le territoires
français alors on m'a fait toutes les
réponses possibles imagines mais peut
pas dire que lafd lafd est un outil de
la solidarité international et de mettre
au même niveau les territoires français
moi je le redis alors on me dit il y a
des spécific
ok on pourrait trans les transvaser
ailleurs mais ça je n'arriveris jamais à
comprendre qu'on puisse dire on est là
je rappelle que la loi prévoyait c'est
de l'aide public au dévelppement sur les
pays elle prévoit même si gouvernement a
changé depuis elle prévoit 19 pays
prioritaires notamment le Sahel et Haïti
et puis au milieu de ça la FD finance
voilà donc soit c'est une banque au quel
cas on peut imaginer dans d'autres
systèmes la CDC BPI France tout ce que
vous voulez et moi je j'arriverai jamais
à comprendre ça et je je voilà c'est
c'est une forme de petit coup de gueule
parce que que je je comprends que là à
un moment donné moi je seraiis euh
habitant d'outrge m excusez-moi vous
utilisez le même outil pour le Soudan le
Mali le Niger et euh la Martinique la
Guadeloupe ou la Nouvelle Calédonie tout
ça me paraît un peu marcher sur la
tête merci euh Vivette Lopez
oui merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure que c'était finalement des
projets modestes compte tenu du budget
que vous avez et pourtant il me semble
que tout à l'heure où j'ai peut-être pas
très bien compris vous avez dit qu'il y
avait peu de projets qui aboutissaient
quelle en est la raison vous avez parlé
que vous interveniez dans dans les
projets sur le sport est-ce qu'il y a
des projets liés avec les Jeux
Olympiques pour l'année prochaine et
concernant l'environnement est-ce que
vous intervenez dans tout ce qui touche
au maritime est-ce que les aires
protégées marines font parti parti des
des projets est-ce qu'il y en a à notre
MRE parce qu'il me semble que quand même
le maritime devrait être pris en compte
surtout dans les outr mèes
merci merci si vouslez bien je vous
laisse la parole et après je passerai la
parole au à Jean-Gérard et Paumier à
Stéphane foissin merci beaucoup je vais
essayer de de répondre aux nombreuses
questions qui montent et été euh euh
posé euh la en ce qui concerne le le
mandat euh de l'Agence française de
développement euh certes le ministère de
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
assure une cotutelle sur
l'opérateur pivot de la coopération
française mais ce n'est pas du tout de
la compétence de la daect donc je prends
bonne note de vos remarques euh que j'ai
d'ailleurs entendu aussi dans la bouche
d'élu euh ultramarin euh mais je ne peux
pas malheureusement euh vous apporter de
réponse je voudrais revenir sur un point
que vous avez évoqué non pas sous forme
de question mais euh mais qui qui a
retenu mon attention à savoir la la
liste des pays prioritaires depuis le
Conseil présidentiel du développement
euh réuni euh au mois de mai de mémoire
je crois le le 5 et puis le side du euh
13 juillet il n'y a plus de liste
prioritair
contraement disposition il n'y a plus de
alors il y a à la fois une
incitation à
soutenir les pays les moins avancés ce
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs très différent
de la liste des pays prioritaires qui
existaient avant alors vous rajoutez le
Cambodge le Népal mais vous n'allez pas
vraiment fondamentalement bouleverser
les géographies mais il y a aussi très
clairement un signal qui a été répété
euh lors de la réunion la Commission
nationale de la coopération
décentralisée par la secrétaire d'État
madame zakara Poulou de diversifier
d'encourager des projets avec d'autres
partenaires je me souviens que madame
zakaropoulou avait parler par exemple du
Nigéria du Kenya d'autres géographies de
ce type-là en ce qui concerne les Jeux
Olympiques euh nous attendons de voir
quels sont les projets certains sont
déjà en cours mais ne nous ont pas été
soumis je crois que nous avons encouragé
les collectivité territoriale à
capitaliser sur la présence
d'équipes
étrangère sur leur territoire parce que
bien évidemment les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques vont concerner d'abord
Paris la scène Saint-Denis mais j'étais
hier encore à Marseille et je sais que
Miramas et le conseil départemental des
bouches du rô veulent
profiter de la présence de
euh de de de la Fédération kéiane
d'athlétisme qui qui n'est pas de
mauvaise
réputation sur leur territoire àiramas
pour avoir même une action autour du
Kenya une maison du Kenya donc je pense
que les collectivités sont bien
sensibles à cette aspect à ce potentiel
que représentent les Jeux Olympiques
au-delà du du territoire
franilien le ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères avait lancé
aussi dans les
ambassades une labellisation terre de
jeu pour
justement encourager les actions dans ce
domain là il y a aussi un partenaire
privilégié en la matière c'est le
Sénégal puisque après les Jeux
Olympiques et
parallympique français en 2024 il y aura
donc les Jeux de la Jeunesse à Dakar en
2026 pour les questions liées à
l'environnement alors rien ne nous
empêche encore une fois d'intervenir
dans le domaine des aires protégées
maritimes mais il nous faut j'is un
projet c'est pas nous avec une petite
équipe une quinzaine de personnes qui
allons construire et en plus je dirais
sans l'expertise nécessaire un projet en
la matière alors c'est vrai pour les les
outres je sais aussi par exemple que le
réseau des grands sites de France ou
certaines collectivités que j'ai eu la
chance de de visiter rcontrer les élus
travaille sur les questions du retrait
de la ligne de côte sur beaucoup de
questions avec des partenaires étrangers
pour comparer les les expériences
d'ailleurs avec des partenaires
lointains ou beaucoup plus proches
certaines collectivités normandes
regardent du côté du Royaume-Uni parce
que même après le brexit on peut
travailler avec entre collectivités
France français et britannique sur ces
questions lié donc au retrait de la
ligne de côte et plus généralement à
toutes ces zones en bord de mer voilà
sur sur ces questions est-ce que j'en
oublie d'autres alors oui sur le budget
c'est effectivement le budget
d'intervention puisque bon le budget de
fonctionnement de toute manière est
fondu dans le budget de fonctionnement
du du du ministère c'est vraiment très 1
millions 15 millions et bien
[Musique]
évidemment je ne devrais pas le dire
mais je vais quand même le dire nous
avons ce budget pour remplir les
objectifs qui ont été fixés par le
Président de la République en matière de
soutien à l'action extérieure des
collectivités territoriales mais il
n'est pas facile de de le
dépenser si on veut rester exigeant sur
la qualité des projets sur leur
faisabilité sachant que certaines
géographies
qui pendant longtemps attiraent beaucoup
de projets de bonne qualité peut-être
aussi de beau volume je pense à la
Russie bien sûr je pense aussi au pays
du Sahel mais ce sont des dossiers qui
sont pour le moment à l'arrêt je ne peux
pas vous dire pour combien de temps je
n'ai pas de capacité pour lire l'avenir
mais donc c'est assez ambitieux d'une
certaine manière ce ce budget surtout
qu'encore une fois nous ne finançons pas
d'infrastructure mais de l'expertise des
études des toutes petites exp des toutes
petites infrastructures quand elles ont
je dirais une vertu pédagogique ou un
prototype qui devra être ensuite
multiplié développé donc oui c'est un un
budget je dirais dont je ne me plains
pas parce que déjà en 30 ans de carrière
comme diplomate c'est assez rare
d'arriver quelque part et de voir un
budget en croissance donc on s'en
réjouit
mais il est suffisant avec les modalités
d'action actuelle si on nous demandait
demain de faire nous-même des projets
bah là il nous faudra d'abord une
expertise que nous n'avons pas et
peut-être un budget supplémentaire en
tout cas justement face à cette
difficulté de monter des projets avec
des collectivités métropolitaine et
ultramarine nous avons d'une certaine
manière amorcé un un un tournant nous
allons à la rencontre de collectivité
territoriale et nous leur proposons de
contractualiser notre soutien euh sous
forme de de convention pour 3 ans alors
bien évidemment nous sommes tenus par le
principe d'annualité budgétaire donc il
y a chaque
année un avenant qui fixe le montant
exact de la subvention mais ça permet à
la fois pour nous de savoir un petit peu
ce qui vient parce que sinon c'était un
peu la grande surprise on lance les
appels à projet et puis qui va nous
répondre dans quel domaine vers quelle
géographie vers quel partenaire là on va
voir quelques grosses collectivités et
je ne sais pas si j'aurai le temps de le
faire personnellement mais j'espère que
ce sera fait par le reste de l'équipe
mais avec l'autre maire sans avoir je
dirais à manifester quelqu préférence
que ce soit je sens que ce serait le
plus possible avec la collectivité
territoriale de Martinique qui est celle
qui a peut-être être le plus articulé
euh une
stratégie non seulement d'intégration
régionale mais également euh j' dirais
de rayonnement
international le le président lechimi ça
sa vice-présidente Patricia tell qui qui
participe au titre de région de France
aux travaux de la CNCD on je crois une
vision peut-être la plus élaborée la
plus claire de ce que peut-être euh
une une une stratégie je dirais en
matière d'action extérieure on retrouve
aussi peut-être du côté de la Réunion un
potentiel mais malheureusement je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion de commencer à
négocier ce type de texte que nous
négocions avec des conseils régionaux je
pense conseil régionaux des haut-fance
avec
certaines métropole comme Paris mais
également Nancy ou d'autres euh euh
voilà mais je pense que ça va être une
démarche parce que sinon nous n'y
arriverons pas avec nos seuls appels à
projet merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
vais laisser la parole à Jean-Gérard
Paumier
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur pour votre exposé
tout à fait
intéressant pour moi en en appui en
cohérence avec avec la diplomatie
française il y a place pour une
diplomatie parlementaire le président
Larcher l'a rappelé hier en accueillant
je dirait une délégation de la
République du Congo mais il me semble
qu'il y a place aussi pour une forme de
diplomatie territoriale j'emploace ce
mot à dessin au-delà de la coopération
décentralisée pour laquelle je ressens
j'ai ressenti comme président de
département pendant cette année une
prudence une frilosité voir une méfiance
du du K d'orsé par rapport à ces
initiatives or je pense qu'il y a
parfois des des signaux faibles qui
mériteraient d'être entendu je voudrais
vous donner un exemple précis il y a
dans mon département de l'indrloire à
côté de tour une ville de 15000
habitants sincir sur Loire qui depuis 25
ans a une coopération avec cousanar au
Sénégal Sénégal puisque leéopold séar
singor était prof de lettre à tour et
bien quand il a était inauguré un centre
social financé par saint-cire il a dû se
battre pour qu'il y ait un drapau
français et un drapeau tricolore de
ruban à côté du drapeau sénégalais parce
que au départ en arrivant lui a dit il
n'y aura que le drapeau sénégalais ce
qui ne manque pas de nous inquiéter dans
un secteur de l'Afrique de l'Ouest où je
dirais la France a commencé
à perdre en influence et la suppression
de votre poste que vous avez signalé
tout à l'heure va bien dans ce sens qui
peut inquiéter les collectivité locale
en terme d'intérêt je dirais pour la
coopération décentralisé des
collectivités quand on poste de conseill
diplomatique auprès des préfectures de
région j'appartiens à une région qui n'a
que six départements je l'ai vu une fois
en 7 ans alors j'ose imaginer ce que
c'est pour ceux dans les grandes régions
qui ont beaucoup de départements donc
ceci m'inquiète beaucoup par contre
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur j'aimerais
connaître je dirais le montant des
budgets des collectivités locales en
regard comme le disait le collègue des
budgets d'action de votre direction que
vous connaissz parce que c'est
intéressant de pouvoir pondérer de dire
quel est l'ensemble si cela existe de ce
que font les collectivités locales un
point me me gêne un tout petit peu dans
dans le propos que vous avez indiqué qui
rejoint celui que nous avons évoqué lors
de l'audition du Conseil d'éta il y a
quelques jour c'est toujours la question
des appels à projet ce côté toujours
descendant et non pas ascendant
descendant même un collègue avait parlé
de condescendant or moi je voulais vous
demander est-ce qu'il a été fait ou
sinon je pense que serait peut-être
intéressant de le faire comment dire un
questionnaire à l'ensemble des
collectivités afin d'avoir un peu un
atlas des différentes actions de leur
contenu et de leur montant pour voir ici
ou là ce qui se fait parce que ça me
paraîtrait intéressant pour l'action que
qui peut être la vôre merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais tout d'abord
euh rendre à à tout seigneur tout
honneur le président de la République a
dû anticiper votre question puisque à
l'issue de la rencontre de Saint-Denis
le 30 août il a annoncé la prochaine
tenue d'assise de la diplomatie
parlementaire et de la coopération
décentralisée entre vous et moi j'aurais
peut-être préféré euh qu'il USA de la
l'expression diplomatie des territoires
euh à laquelle je crois beaucoup mais
euh cette initiative même s'il faut
encore la mettre en œuvre la formaliser
je comprends qu'elle pourrait donc
prendre recp à la fin du mois de janvier
début du mois de février est très
importante euh bien sûr pour les
parlementaires mais également pour les
élus locaux qui avaient besoin de sentir
qu'ils étaient traités j'irais non pas
d'égal à égal
mais un petit peu de la même manière que
les
parlementaires qui ont été élu il y
avait je crois une petite
inquiétude ces derniers temps de voir
les élus locaux un peu noyé dans
une masse si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
que l'on désigne de société civile or
avec tout le respect que l'on doit aux
associations de la société civile CIV
avoir un mandat électoral des
responsabilités qui viennent du suffrage
universel ce n'est pas la même chose ce
n'est pas de la même nature que d'être
très actif au sein d'une
association
aussi efficace soit-elle donc c ces
assises nous contribuons à à les
préparer au moins pour le volet donc
coopération décentralisée je crois que
ça sera un rendez-vous très important
d'ailleurs si j'ai
bien retenu donc les les propos du
président c'est une première édition qui
va se tenir
et qui devrait se répéter peut-être
annuellement j'entends tout à fait ce
que vous dites sur le caractère parfois
descendant voire condescendant alors j'y
suis particulièrement attentif de longue
date mais plus particulièrement depuis
que j'ai pris mes fonctions à la daect
parce que je suis doublement suspect aux
yeux des élus locaux comme fonctionnair
d'État et parisien donc forcément je ne
pouvais être
que je dirais propice à une approche
descendante pour ne pas dire
condescendante alors je voudrais vous
dire tout d'abord que nos appels à
projet nous en discutons dans cette
instance qui est la Commission nationale
de la coopération décentralisée parce
que il est encore une fois peut-être
difficile de s'adresser aux
35500 communes de France pour savoir ce
qu'elle voudrait bien faire et
deuxièmement elles sont à l'initiative
donc on ne leur interdit pas ce qui est
très difficile c'est de les convaincre
de l'intérêt de faire quelque chose et
vous tous qui avez été jeais en
responsabilité peut-être à l'échelon
municipal vous savez combien ben
l'action extérieure c'est pas forcément
bien perçu c'est un peu si je puis me
permettre l'expression la danseuse ou en
tout cas la variable d'ajustement euh
beaucoup d'élus m'ont expliqué récemment
ben vous savez quand vous devez faire
passer une diminution de 2 degrés de la
température de l'eau de la piscine c'est
peut-être pas le moment d'arriver avec
votre projet
euh sous des destinations plus
ensoleillées très
lointaines N'ALLEZ PAS ÊTRE votre
conseil municipal va pas bien se passer
si si si vous devez prendre les mêmes
décisions euh le même jour cette volonté
de
coconstruire nous l'avons par exemple
dans cette approche que je mentionnais
avec les 10 villes qui ont ce label de
ville créative de l'UNESCO alors parce
que là c'est plus facile elles sont
identifiées nous les connaissons sont
div villes alors très différentes mais
par certains côtés comparable
nous sommes en train de construire ce
programme en interrogeant les maires de
Ch ch ville bon je les ai déjà rencontré
dans le cas de d'angoulem limog rouan
mes donc pour savoir exactement comment
au mieux on pourrait les aider à
rayonner à l'international à partir de
ce label qu'elles ont obtenu
de ville créative de de l'UNESCO alors
sur le travail des CDPR je dois vous
dire que beaucoup de de de progrès ont
été fait
euh grâce à nos nos nos collègues de la
direction des affaires européennes et
internationales du ministère de
l'intérieur mais aussi grâce à
l'engagement de plusieurs collègues au
sein du ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères ces postes ne sont
pas très anciens ne sont pas bien connus
encore euh beaucoup de de collègues
n'ont pas vraiment encore identifier
leur rôle nous avons fait un travail euh
d'élaboration par exemple d'un vmcom euh
nous avons un travail de communication
même en interne parce que tant que les
CDPR ne seront pas connus de tous les
rédacteurs géographique du qu d'orset il
n'y aura pas un lien une circulation
suffisante d'information entre les
services centraux du ministère et ce
réseau des CDPR nous avons aujourd'hui
même une visionférence que que que
présidera le directeur des affaires
européennes et internationales du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour rendre
compte
de l'état des dossiers justice affaires
intérieures parce que c'est
indispensable que les CDPR et le niveau
d'information suffisant pour être
capable de conseiller non seulement le
préfet mais également les élus qui se
tournent vers eux je dois vous dire que
dans beaucoup de domaines je pense en
particulier les relations avec la Chine
qui sont toujours très
compliqué mais également je pense aussi
au relations avec les pays du Sahel les
CDPR sont de plus en plus souvent
consultés par les élus locaux parce que
les élus locaux ont bien compris que CIT
des collègues de la maison ils avaient
plus de facilités pour appeler le Kor
pour savoir exactement que faire comment
faire encore une fois ce n'est jamais
très simple par exemple avec le
partenaire les partenaires chinois
est-ce qu'il faut accepter ça paraît
mirfique comme offre mais est-ce qu'il y
a pas derrière quelque chose ils sont là
pour conseiller aussi les collectivités
territoriales nous avons déjà du mal à
pourvoir tous les postes de CDPR
certaines régions n'en ont pas encore ou
n'en ont pas
temporairement l'idéal ce serait
peut-être d'en avoir à l'échelon du
département mais
là il faudrait vraiment considérablement
renforcer les nos effectifs mais je
pense qu' à l'échelot régional même pour
les les très grandes régions c'est et je
vous cacherai pas que moi-même depuis 2
ans j'ai parcouru beaucoup de de
territoires je ne suis pas allé
malheureusement en
indréloire si mais si mais si bien sûr
je suis passé un tour plusieurs fois
mais euh
j'aiai jamais refusé un déplacement à
l'invitation d'un élu
local merci je vais laisser la parole à
notre collègue Stéphane foissin oui ma
question rejoignent un petit peu le
problème des finances bon ça a été
répondu
euh vous savez que dans il y a des
mesures du sium qui vont nous permettre
effectivement de pouvoir travailler avec
les pays de la zone pour concernant les
matériaux et la mise au norme des des
matériaux pour qu'il qu'on puisse les
accueillir sur nos
territoire avez-vous des projets dans le
cadre du développement économique dans
où est-ce que c'est possible de d'en
faire et deuxièmement est-ce que vous
avez un fcule explicatif à destination
des collectivités pour leur donner le le
cheminement ou le la façon de de
travailler avec vos servicees ce serait
bien d'avoir quelque chose de de clair
qu'on puisse distribuer c'est lorsqu'on
revient dans nos circonscriptions c'est
quelque chose pour nous d'important
euh voilà et oui c'était surtout ça et
la coopération parlementaire mais on l'
abordé aussi donc parfait merci beaucoup
monsieur le le sénateur euh en matière
de de je dirais soutien euh à l'activité
économique il y a euh d'autres services
ou opérateurs de l'État qui sont plus
spécialisés euh mais euh encore une fois
le le le champ économique n'est pas
exclu de la coopération décentralisée
pour nous ce qui est très important
c'est qu'il est toujours ce lien
politique de part et d'autre mais euh
sans vouloir déflorer euh un accord qui
n'est pas encore signé mais c'est dans
le domaine de la transition
euh écologique que nous travaillons avec
le Conseil Régional de Grand Est pour
une plateforme avec l'ensemble de
l'Allemagne et pas seul ement les
lenders voisins du Grand Est c'est
clairement je dirais un projet avec une
forte dimension économique nous
comprenons bien que les conseils
régionaux en particulier ont besoin
d'un d'un soutien en la matière nous
nous intervenons au tout départ au
moment je dirais de l'amorçage des
projets au moment de l'échange
d'expertise pour élaborer après quelque
chose de plus gros qui sera soutenu par
de des moyens plus plus adéquats alors
comment faisons-nous connaître notre
action écoutez moi j'ai pris mes
fonctions devait être entre la 8e et 9e
vague de covid donc c'était pas
exactement le moment le plus propice
pour signonner toute la France
métropolitaine et
ultramarine mais nous nous appuyons en
partie sur les associations de
collectivité territoriales nous nous
appuyons sur les réseaux régionaux
multiacteurs alors ces réseaux régionaux
multiacteurs c'est
c'est sont des structures qui n'ont pas
toutes la même euh les mêmes moyens ça
c'est sûr mais ni même la même forme
juridique dans la région g renalpe c'est
un Jeep dans les autres régions quand il
en existe il y en a pas par exemple en
Île-de-France c'est un euh c'est une
structure associative l'intérêt du rrma
c'est qu'autour de la table vous avez à
la fois des collect iité territoriale
généralement le conseil régional prend
une part importante mais également les
conseils départementaux jusqu'à des plus
petites communes il y a des toujours des
barêmes dégressifs pour être membrre de
ce rrma mais également des partenaires
essentiels comme les instituts de
recherche les organisations de
solidarité internationale les lycées
agricoles les chambres des métiers donc
ils connaissent nos appels à projet la
vraie difficulté
c'est c'est d'avoir la compétence de
monter les projets et même
si nous faisons tous les efforts
possibles pour simplifier nos appels à
projet sachant que nous avons quand même
des obligations de de rendre compte il
s'agit d'argent public donc on peut pas
dire écoutez vous nous vous nous
racontez une histoire expliquant ce que
vous voulez faire on vous envoie un
chèque et tout est bon comme
cela nos appels à projet sont quand même
beaucoup beaucoup plus simples que des
app un projet européen par exemple je
heureusement puisque ce sont pas du tout
les mêmes montants entre des fonds
Interreg et ce que nous apportons la DA
C on n'est pas du tout du tout dans le
même monde mais il faudrait pas que nos
appels à projet soient éminemment
complexe comme peuvent l'être les appels
à projets européens donc nous essayons
de simplifier mais il est vrai que dans
beaucoup de collectivités territorial il
n'y a pas en face une personne capable
de monter ce projet surtout que la
difficulté c'est pas seulement de
convaincre celui qui l'élu ou dans les
services qui a parmi ces ces nombreuses
étiquettes celle de la coopération
décentralisée ou de la relation
internationale c'est de convaincre les
collègues qui sont en charge des espaces
verts c'est de convaincre les collègues
qui sont en charge de la gestion de
l'eau de participer à ces projets
internationaux c'est pas dans leur
réflexe naturel ils n'ont pas forcément
le temps pourquoi développer un projet
très lointain quand on a déjà peu de
temps pour Ben gérer ce que l'on a à
faire euh à l'échelle locale je crois
que c'est plutôt ça la difficulté mais
bien évidemment nous avons des fasicules
nous
participons je je suis toutes les je
dirais grandes réunions de collectivité
territorial depuis les congrès de région
de France département de France Salon
des Maires mais ça je veux dire on est
invisible au Salon des Maires tant il y
a de participants euh mais nous sommes
toujours à la disposition je me rends le
plus possible je dirais dans les dans
les territoires mais c'est plus au-delà
de faire connaître comment aider et et
et là avec nos collègues de l'Agence
française de développement nous
travaillons pour un renforcement des
capacités des équipes autour des des
élus locaux pour monter ces projets mais
c'est particulièrement le cas en outrem
euh je crois et une dernière chose que
je voudrais mentionner sur des handicaps
de l'outr quand ils soumettent des
projets c'est nous comparons les projets
forcément les membres des comités de
sélection or les projets ultramarins
sont toujours d'une certaine manière un
peu pénalisé parce qu'ils ont
euh une partie des dépenses qui paraît
absolument excessif quand on connaît pas
bien la la la réalité des territoire
ultramarin en matière de de billets
d'avion mais malheureusement pour aller
d'une île à l'autre en dans les Antilles
vous dépensez souvent plus que pour
aller de Paris à
Dakar donc on se dit mais mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que ça alors c'est
particulièrement vrai pour les les les
projets liés au sport parce que vous
montez un très bon projet et structurant
c'est ce qu'on recherche parce qu'on ne
veut pas juste une fois un échange entre
l'équipe minime de tel territoire et
l'équipe minime de l'autre territoire on
veut quelque chose de structurant avec
une formation des des cadres et mais on
regarde les billets d'avion c'est ce
projet non ils exagèrent non oui sauf
que et ben vous regardez après euh sur
le meilleur site que vous connaissez
pour comparer les prix des billets
d'avion mais ça sera beaucoup plus cher
euh de les envoyer peut-être en Jamaïque
ou ou je ne sais où euh que d'envoyer
des jeunes depuis Paris à Dakar
juste m'excuser madame la Présidente
mais on a une niche RDPI qui commence à
10h30 au lieu de 11h30 donc on est
obligé de vous quittez en tout cas
c'était très intéressant merci merci
beaucoup merci je vais laisser la parole
à notre collègue Jacqueline stage Brig
merci Madame la président oui je voulais
aborder de deux sujets dans le cadre de
notre s aujourd'hui sur les projets dont
vous avez parlé sport la culture ce qui
est extrêmement intéressant moi je suis
étonnée qu'il n'y ait rien ou en tout
cas rien de suscité de de solliciter sur
la formation l'emploi on sait quand même
que dans ces territoires ultramarin
c'est un vrai sujet la formation
l'emploi avec une population jeune je
suis quand même étonné qu'on naborde pas
ce sujet-l dans le casadre de cette
coopération de de de voilà parce que
c'est un vrai sujet vous avez dit tout à
l'heure au début de vos propos que un
certain nombre d'habitants de C
territoire partaient au Québec par
exemple parce que c'est à 6h d'avion par
exemple de la Guadeloupe et c'est vrai
que le Québec peut être attractif et
pourquoi pas j'ai envie de dire mais
mais du coup ça je trouve étonnant qu'on
en parle pas tout comme on parle pas du
tout non plus des problèmes de sécurité
délinquence qui est aussi un sujet voilà
c'est une difficulté c'est un sujet
alors c'est pas un jugement B ni rien
mais c'est peut-être aussi des sujets
sur lequels il faudrait réfléchir ou
peut-être susciter une réflexion dans le
cadre de cette coopération parce que euh
on ne peut pas aborder ces territoires
sans aborder ces deux thématiques qui
sont quand même à mon sens prioritaires
sur les territoires ultramarins je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez merci beaucoup
madame le
sénateur nous avons regroupé dans le
thème
jeunesse plusieurs dimensions et il y a
dedans cette dimension Formation Emploi
alors est-ce qu'il aurait fallu la la la
distinguer avoir un appel à projet
spécifique pour nous je dois vous dire
c'est plus plus simple aussi de gérer la
une dizaine une quinzaine d'appels à
projet sous le vocable général jeunesse
que d'avoir à réunir trois comités de
sélection mais mais vous avez raison
peut-être qu'il faudrait plus clairement
signaler cette priorité je pense en part
il y a des projets je pense en
particulier un projet qui avait retenu
toute mon attention peut-être parce que
je suis gourmand mais un projet de
mobilité des apprentis boulangers et
pâtissiers de la Réunion dans la zone
Océan Indien euh il faut savoir que nos
jeunes formés dans tous les métiers de
bouche et de services sont prisés ils
sont bien formés et mais ils ont aussi
besoin de de gagner en expérience à
l'étranger notamment pour
indirectement améliorer leurs
compétences linguistiqu donc nous avons
ce ce ce très beau projet avec le
conseil départemental de la Réunion
c'est un exemple euh mais je comprends
bien votre euh votre préoccupation et
que que nous partageons euh il y en a
pas assez euh peut-être qu'il faudrait
je crois euh que nous nous
rapprochions non pas uniquement des
collectivités territoriales mais
également des organismes de formation
professionnelle non pas pour les
soutenir directement c'est pas dans la
mission de la DAEC mais qu'ells aillent
voir ensuite le leurs élus préférés pour
leur dire ben voilà on a un très beau
projet en la matière on a besoin que
Monsieur le Maire Monsieur le Président
que vous vous vous le repreniez à votre
compte pas seulement je en contesignant
le projet d' organisme de formation
professionnelle mais en le portant avec
un partenaire étranger c'est c'est pe le
domaine de la sécurité nous l'avons pas
du tout abordé
[Musique]
oui je ne sais pas encore non non mais
encore une fois nous sommes dans cette
position à la FO trs conforable
d'attendre les initives des
collectivités le libre administration le
priorités mais nous n'avons pas suscité
quelque chose de
particulier merci
m merci madame la Présidente
l'ambassadeur j'ai juste une question
une question assez complexe mais je
remercie le collègue d'avoir évoqué les
territoir de la nouvellealédonie la
Polynésie française et volftuna tout à
l'heure puisque on est un peu victime de
cette distorsion je veux dire politique
et administrative hein qui qui touche le
l'économique développement économique
notamment en parlant de
lafd par contre je voulais venir un peu
sur rebondir un peu sur le point de la
diplomatie parlementaire parce que je
pense que on est une région pacifique
qui
qui est très bien placé au niveau de la
de l'axe indopacifique et je je dis ça
parce que je pense que l'actualité et
les craintes de l'État c'est bien sûr
les relations avec la
présence très prononcé de la Chine dans
la région donc je j'avais soumis un peu
l'idée auprès des ministères aussi bien
de l'intérieur que de l'autre ma euh à
savoir si on pouvait former une enfin
c'est une suggestion mais à étudier avec
la délégation des outromur parce que il
est très important qu'on fasse le lien
entre l'État et la région pacifique dans
le sens où je je peux me permettre de
dire qu'en Polynésie et en
Nouvelle-Calédonie on a déjà deux
gouvernements
indépendantistes voyez et vous voyez la
délicatesse euh donc quelque part il
faut peut-être réagir
rapidement et instaurer quelque chose
qui puisse redresser un peu la barre à
ce niveau-là parce que je pense que
l'État devrait mettre le doigt dans les
difficultés réelles des des
collectivités du du Pacifique pour
savoir exactement pourquoi il y a ces
réactions même si au niveau politique il
y a des il y a eu des maladresses aussi
h mais je je pense que au niveau de
l'État il faudrait que
qu'on approfondisse la réflection sur la
création la mise en place d'une région
Pacifique pour palier au problème de de
l'axe Indo-Pacifique voilà madame la
Présidente et Monsieur l'Ambassadeur la
question un peu complexe que que je
voulais poser mais je pense que il y a
autre chose qui pourrait me revenir à
l'esprit parce que ça me ça
me ça me
ronge je l'ai évoqué hier au niveau de
la
QAG que pour W par
exemple et ça ça me gêne énormément d'en
parler quand on sait qu'on est inscrit
sur la liste de l'OCDE c'est comme si on
était à part voyez et c'est ça qui me
gêne c'est comme si on était un pays
sous développé qu'on était pas
français et ça depuis
2009 toutes ces problématiques je je
soulève parce que je je suis arrivé en
2012 à l'Assemblée territoriale avec une
petite expérience métropolitaine bien
sûr au niveau de l'État mais ça ça m'a
ça m'a secouer parce que excusez-moi le
terme mais quelque part si j'en ai parlé
hier lors de ma AG c'est que c'est la
réalité et ça me gêne que quand on parle
de la FD et autrre on a même pas le
droit à l'aide publique au développement
hein si on est bien sûr sur cette liste
de l'OCDE voilà
merci merci chers
collègues merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur alors je suis euh très gêné
parce que vos questions me vont à la
fois droite au cœur je vous ai pas
expliqué tout le déroulé de ma carrière
ça n'avait pas intérêt mais je suis
quand même rentré au kéoret comme par le
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque grand
concours d'Orient euh dans la section
Extrême Orient Pacifique donc ce sont
des questions qui m'ont toujours
intéressé et j'ai eu en plus la chance
je suis peut-être un des rares dans
cette salle à m'être rendu non seulement
en Nouvelle-Calédonie mais également à
WIS et Futuna donc j'en ai gardé
d'excellents souvenir alors euh je ne
peux pas répondre à vos questions
puisque je le disais en introduction La
daect n'est pas compétente pour les
questions du Pacifique je voudrais juste
mentionner ce qui n'est qu'une petite
contribution à une réponse aux questions
que vous soulevez
euh dans les différentes réformes
entreprises par lequ d'orset suite aux
états généraux de la diplomatie il y a
la constitution d'une académie
diplomatique et une des choses euh très
importante si ce n'était que de la
formation interne des diplommats je
dirais j'en parlerai peut-être pas
maintenant mais cette académie va être
ouverte aussi aux fonctionnaires
territoriaux et je pense que c'est très
important que des services que soit en
Nouvelle-Calédonie waliss Futuna ou dans
toutes les autres collectivité
ultramarine saisissent l'occasion en
profit pour envoyer aussi leur le leurs
agents se former débattre aussi parce
que je je pense que ça sera pas
seulement une suite suite de conférence
je l'espère en tout cas une suite de
conférence une suite de leçon qu'on
donnerait à des participants mais je
pense qu'il y aura quand même du coup
une meilleure compréhension d'enjeux
globaux qui
touch de très près les territoir
français du Pacifique mais qui
s'inscrivent dans un cadre général très
complexe de la politique
extérieure de la Chine et d'autres
grands acteurs aussi l'Inde par exemple
ne doit pas être nég dans la lecture de
ce qui se passe dans le
monde Indo paacifique mais
malheureusement je peux pas vous
répondre davantage sur les autres
aspects que vous évoquez puisque ce
n'est pas de la la compétence de ma
délégation merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
je terminerai ces ces questions par deux
points que vous avez pour lequel vous
avez en partie répondu euh vous avezvqué
la Martinique qui qui est très en avant
dans dans la stratégie régionale de de
développement justement le fait que les
autres territoires ne soient pas aussi
avancés ne serait-il pas lié à une un
manque de formation un manque de
connaissance et des élus et du personnel
administratif ne pourrait-on pas
envisager un poste fléché
spécifiquementop tion régionale et aussi
lorsque vous avez mentionné le prix des
billets d'avion il y a aussi une
méconnaissance au sein des instances
nationales une méconnaissance de la
situation des territoires et pour
rejoindre sur le prix des billets
d'avion quelques aberrations puisque
nous parlons de coopération régionale
pour se rendre de Guadeloupe à Cuba nous
devons pas traverser l'océan pour aller
à Paris et revenir de Paris à Cuba donc
il il y a vraiment lieu de se pencher
sur ces
questions merci beaucoup euh je ne
voudrais pas oublier euh au cours de cet
échange de mentionner
euh non seulement l'existence mais
surtout le travail très utile que font
mes collègues ambassadeurs régionaux
Océan Indien et alors il s'appelle plus
caraï puisqueil maintenant il a
compétence également pour Pier et miklon
donc ce doit être Amérique euh mais euh
ils sont alors vraiment à pied d'œuvre
pour euh je dirais renforcer euh cette
coopération régionale euh de nos
territoires que ce soit euh dans le
bassin pacifique ou dans euh le bassin
Atlantique ou le bassin indien euh en ce
qui concerne la la
Martinique moi je vais pas me permettre
de de juger une collectivité par rapport
à une autre mais je vois qu'il est quand
même peut-être plus commode d'avoir un
interlocuteur euh donc l'échelon région
et département confondus que quand vous
en avez plusieurs euh il y a peut-être
aussi l'engagement très fort du
président de la collectivité
territoriale il y a tout de même une loi
qui porte même son nom en matière
d'action extérieure euh c'est pas tout à
fait un hasard alors je comprends que
d'autres élus peuvent avoir d'autres
priorités mais ce n'est pas je dirais
euh sans sans sans conséquence nous
n'avons pas mentionné euh le mot
euh de Mayotte et je me sentirai
coupable de ne pas du tout parler de de
Mayotte au cours de cet échange je dois
vous dire que Mayotte est confronté
malheureusement à une difficulté
supplémentaire par rapport aux
autres collectivités ultramarines c'est
que ces
voisins
immédiat ne lui mène pas la vie facile
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire donc
des projets qui auraiit tout à fait un
sens entre Mayot et les Comores ont
parfois
avorté parce que les autorités des
Comores ne reconnaissaient pas la
possibilité pour Mayot mais bon vous
connaissez l'histoire de Mayot son
statut donc c'est encore plus difficile
pour
Mayotte de nouer je dirais des des lien
avec son environnement régional
Mayotte est sujet à toutes sortes de
tracasserie à chaque fois qu'elle
participe à des événements sportifs
régionaux encore une fois c'est une des
manif manifestation les plus les plus
visibles de l'intégration régionale ces
jeux
régionaux la réunion n'a pas de
difficulté pour y participer Mayotte
c'est à chaque fois une longue
négociation pour obtenir la la
participation des sportifs de cette
collectivité je vais pas oublier de le
mentionner parce que Mayot qui aurait
peut-être encore plus besoin que
d'autres collectivités de
s'insérer dans son
environnement immédiat a peut-être
encore plus de mal alors du coup je
DIRIS il y a une certaine
résilience
admirable chez chez les élus de de
Mayotte ils essayent de développer avec
d'autres partenaires je pense
dibouti Madagascar
euh mais encore une fois ça serait je
dirais naturellement plutôt avec les
Comor qui devrait avoir un lien
privilégié mais là les relations
sont difficiles c'est le moins qu'on
puisse
dire merci euh y y a-t-il d'autres
questions non donc avant de avant de
avant de clôturer cette audition et vous
remercier de nouveau pour la qualité des
des échanges et des information que vous
nous avez apporté euh je note que le
bassin Pacifique nentre pas dans le
champ d'action de la DECT au
regret les collectivités ultramarine
participe peu aux aux appels à projet
donc essayer de
comprendre pourquoi et peut-être se très
certainement se renseigner auprès de
celles qui ont mis en place des
stratégies d'intégration régionale en
particulier la la Martinique mais aussi
des des projets innovants comme celui
que vous avez évoqué à la à la réunion
sur la
formation des dans le domaine du
tourisme donc euh nous avons nous sommes
ravis d'avoir pu euh bénéficier de votre
de votre expertise et cela nous a ouvert
à la suite de nos travaux euh pour euh
participer à une meilleure coopération
dans les dans les collectivités dans les
territoires merci à vous
merp
votre contribution écrite sera aussi la
bienvenue